[Musique]
petite j'ai eu des moments d'ennui
un peu comme vous j'imagine un des
moments d'ennui seul dans ma chambre
des moments d'ennui à l'école beaucoup
des moments d'ennui pendant les
interminables repas de fête de famille
ouais ça vous parle
et aussi beaucoup d'ennuis lors des
longs départs les trajets en vacances en
voiture
alors ça va pas me rajeunir parce qu'à
l'époque j'avais enfin mes parents
surtout avait une déesse et à l'époque
aussi il n'y avait pas les écrans n'y
avait pas les tablettes y avait pas les
nintendo il n'y avait pas les
smartphones etc y avait bien la lecture
mais ça me fait vomir surtout dans la ds
donc du coup je n'avais d'autre choix
que de m'ennuyer
alors je partais dans des contrées
invisible je partais voir les faits je
partais voir les luttes à pétrole
j'oubliais le temps je brillais l'espace
j'oubliais le temps qui passe ces longs
moments d'ennui
dynaction de silence ont largement
contribué à ce que j'explore mon
intériorité à développer mon imaginaire
à écouter mes ressentis et à affiner mon
intuition d'enfants du coup je crois
beaucoup au fait je crois beaucoup à
l'intuition et je crois beaucoup aux
vertus des ennuis alors si on vous
proposait un peu pendant ce tête ça va
vous changer de vous ennuyer
ça tombe bien je vais passer la parole à
alexis
alors c'est intéressant cette notion
d'intériorité que mentionne marié stèle
puisque étymologiquement le mot
intuition vient du latin et ça veut dire
percevoir regarder attentivement à
l'intérieur de soi
alors on a tous notre petite définition
notre petite idée de ce qu'est
l'intuition
selon notre vécu selon nos expériences
selon nos croyances et donc en fait il
ya beaucoup de mots oui pour l'infusion
les bouteilles ao oui voilà c'est bien
il ya beaucoup de mots par exemple la
petite voix intérieure sixième sens
pourquoi pas ressenti jeu peut-être plus
commun par exemple typiquement c'est le
gotta feeling c'est à dire ce mot de nos
amis anglophones qui veut dire ressenti
qui provient des tripes
oui il ya aussi prémonition
pressentiment précognition clairvoyance
flers illuminations bref vous l'aurez
compris il ya beaucoup d'appellations et
de synonymes pour pour ce qui concerne
l' intuition en tant que tel alors du
coup je vais en fonction de vos
croyances est de votre vécu
vous avez cette définition là qui vous
convient pour l'intuition alors que
croire qu'ils croient pour un mois alors
faisons simple faisons sage
regardons tout simplement dans le
dictionnaire et dont le dictionnaire en
fait la définition de l'intuition ses
capacités à avoir des connaissances
apercevoir avant l'information de
manière directe immédiate sens de la
vérité
une connaissance de la vérité directes
immédiates sans avoir recours aux
raisonnements et sans s'appuyer sur
notre vécu nos expériences antérieures
donc
tout simplement si on est logique
l'intuition n'est pas du raisonnement et
si on poursuivre ce chemin logique
l'intuition et par conséquent n'est pas
de ré du raisonnement inconscient voilà
une première croyance qui est mise à mal
l'intuition perçoit nazis intuition
perçoit voilà elle ne déduit par exemple
concret marie estelle a caché dans une
de ses poches un objet mystère et s'ils
ont joué ensemble
je vous demande et de percevoir et
décrire cet objet mystère disons en un
minimum de 5
adjectif par exemple la couleur
caractéristique de cet objet mystère
comment est-elle ou la forme
caractéristique ou les formes
caractéristiques de cet objet comment
sont elles les odeurs peut-être où les
sons et peut-être là où les textures
caractéristiques convertis alors
peut-être heures qui parmi vous a eu
déjà l'idée d'un objet quand on a évoqué
cet exercice ça peut être pourquoi pas
vous avez pécule idée j'ai pas comme on
attend le ticket de tramway
ça peut être une ou des clés ou une ou
des pièces de monnaie qui faites pas vos
timide qui a eu cette idée
voilà on envoie tout à fait normal
alors pour ceux qui ont eu cette image
mentale cette idée de clés de trousseau
de trousseaux de clés de pièces de
monnaie de mouchoirs qu'est ce qui s'est
passé qu'est ce que vous vous êtes dit
ou plutôt qu'est-ce que votre
raisonnement de manière consciente ou
inconsciente vous a dit mais voilà en
général dans les poches
si on a un objet c'est que ces petits ce
n'est pas d'intuition
ça c'est de la déduction deuxième étape
votre intellect votre capacité à
analyser les choses s'est dit ok c'est
dans la poche ces petits en général
qu'est-ce qu'on trimballe dans les
poches
la tique et trams pièces de monnaie
mouchoirs là aussi on n'est pas dans un
tuyau on est dans des a priori ou des
projections
comment éviter de tomber dans le panneau
dans ce piège du mental tout simplement
quand vous allez faire ce jeu avec
alexis qui va vous guider par des
questionnements pensez juste apprendre
les perceptions première c'est à dire
que vous allez décrire l'objet et non
pas identifié ou essayer de nommer
rester dans la description avec des
adjectifs prenez les perceptions
première avant que le raisonnement ne
s'en mêle donc là on vous invite à
prendre le smartphone et puis vous une
feuille ou un crayon pour pouvoir faire
cet exercice
voilà alors tout nombreux commence
vraiment fait l'exercice l'exercice
comme dender marie estelle je vais
simplement vous poser des questions
typiquement sensorielle et puis vous
allez percevoir des choses la veurdée
ressenti vous allez avoir des idées
prenez note tout ce qui vous vient à
l'esprit si jamais vous avez moi je vais
vous poser des questions comment l objet
si jamais vous avez des idées qu'il
réponde à la question qu'est-ce que
l'objet en fait si vous avez une idée de
ce que peut être l'objet vous notez et
vous mettez de côté et en fait parce que
c'est probablement pas ça c'est votre
intellect qui moulinent petit vélo
mental tout ça voilà alors choper
finalement les premières perception
ressenti qui vous viennent dès que je
vous pose une question
alors c'est parti cet objet
nous allons tous voir d'ici quelques
instants cet objet mystère qui est dans
la poche de marie estelle et bien
percevez cet objet quand vous le
regardez sa couleur caractéristique
aller comment prenez conscience de sa
couleur noté cet objet quand vous êtes
en interaction avec quand vous touchez
par exemple quand vous passez la main
dessus sur la paume de votre main au
niveau de la texture c'est comment
prenez conscience de la texture noté
cet objet vous pouvez appuyer dessus
vous pouvez même taper dessus ça fait
comment au niveau de la dureté à noter
cet objet pourquoi pas vous pouvez le
soupeser quand vous supposez cet objet
ça fait comment notez pourquoi pas vous
pouvez observer regarder ou avec le
toucher toujours donc avec la vue ou
avec le toucher percevez la forme
caractéristique noté fait un petit
croquis tout simple croquis gamme 25 ans
continuez d'explorer vous pouvez par
exemple écouter l'objet l'objet fait-il
un son si oui comment
et vous pouvez aussi secoué l'objet
comment elles sont que vous percevez 6
en 1 décrivez noter vous pouvez pourquoi
pas goûté cet objet gut est l'objet ça
fait comment en bouche cet objet peu
importe sa taille initiale vous mettez
tout petit et qu'un petit truc de pain
surprise hommes étaient dans votre
bouche et vous ressentez commence à fait
dans votre bouche maintenant vous pouvez
pourquoi pas mâché et avaler ça fait
comment reprenez taille humaine la même
votre échelle propres par rapport à
l'échelle de cet objet observé de
nouveau cet objet regardez vous pouvez
pourquoi pas aller à l'intérieur mais on
va encore bouger à l'intérieur c'est
comment prenez conscience pour les
contacts avec cet objet de l'intérieur
et sait comment au niveau des couleurs
des formes des odeurs des sons noter
tout ce qui vous vient
et quand vous êtes en interaction avec
cet objet comment sont les gestes que
vous faites
notez une fois que c'est fait et bien
marie estelle va vous montrer comment
est cet objet est alors monté montrer
aussi la dia poivre alors soyez
simplement je lutterai quelque chose
soyez objectifs avec vous même c'est à
dire qu'on a tendance à se dire ou es ce
que j'ai fait c'est trop génial ou ses
trois nuls
l'homme aime bien se flageller donc
c'est plutôt trop nul soyez objectifs et
regarder et comparer tout ce que vous
avez obtenus avec votre intuition avec
vos perceptions par rapport à comment
est réellement l'objet sceptiques il
m'arrive au j'ai réussi ce coup ci a vu
bon c'est un yoyo si vous avez eu des
perceptions des caractéristiques telles
que jaune lumineux seront transparents
brillant au toucher lisse ou voyages
parlant adjectif il ya du métallique
aussi pour ceux qui auraient perçu du
métalliques
il ya du bruit de normalement il doit
faire du bruit voilà un de l'eia du
lumineux dont il ya plein de
caractéristiques et ça ce sont vos
perceptions première tout ce qui est
l'identification les pièces de monnaie
vous mettez de côté vous l'aurez compris
l'intuition perçoit elle ne déduit pas
quand parfois vous vous dites un ravin
mais j'aurais pas dû suivre une
intuition
demandez vous plutôt qui vous avez suivi
est ce que c'est votre raisonnement ou
est ce que c'est votre intuition
l'intuition et toujours juste voilà une
deuxième croyance qu on déboulonne si
elle est fausse et que ça n'était pas de
l'intuition c'est autre chose
rappelez-vous le dictionnaire le dit
lui-même l'intuition c'est une
connaissance immédiate de la vérité de
la verrerie
on continue ouais vous en voulez une
autre de croyance hockey à ce jeu merci
d'avoir dit oui parce que sinon elle
était mal
quand même à ce jeu intuitif qu'est ce
que vous avez fait vous avez sollicité
votre intuition
en fait on est tous intuitif on a tous
la capacité d'utiliser notre intuition
tout comme notre intellect résonne 24
heures sur 24 votre intuition vous donne
en continu des informations
par contre ça c'est scientifiquement
mise en évidence par contre tout l'enjeu
ici c'est de reconnaître votre intuition
parmi les soixante mille pensées par
jour qui traverse votre esprit petit
exemple personnel j'étais gamin je
devais avoir 8 9 10 ans et j'étais dans
le salon chez mes parents bien
évidemment et je regardais la télé à
l'époque c'était en noir et blanc un
vieux tube cathodique du genre deux
chaînes prochainement et c'était un
documentaire un reportage il y avait un
homme qui est habillé avec une blouse
blanche et qui dans une salle avec une
grosse machine métallique je comprenais
pas ce qui se passait vraiment et cette
machine à rêves aussi des grandes
bobines qui tournait les manifestement
d'après ce qui est tendance qui a été
dit cette machine faisait des calculs
compliqués et j'ai tout d'un coup en
fait à ce moment là ça m'a surpris moi
même j'ai eu l'idée
j'ai su en fait que plus tard je ferai
le même métier que cette personne alors
je suis allé tout de suite dans la
cuisine où ma mère faisait à manger et
je les années j'ai donné mes parents
pour qui m'achètent cette machine qui
faisait plein de calculs complexes
trop cher trop gros pour les pompiers
néanmoins vingt ans plus tard 1998 je
suis devenu chercheur en informatique
oui donc de savoir pour peu savoir
intuitivement pour peu qu'on s'interroge
cirque on se pose des questions ce qu'on
a fait tout à l'heure pour peu qu'on
s'écoute c'est ce qu'on a fait tout à
l'heure aussi et pour peu qu'on se fasse
confiance
on peut savoir intuitivement
en fait on pense effectivement on pense
souvent on croit souvent que l'intuition
est spontanée elle ne peut être que
spontané que non maîtrisée c'est faux
encore une autre croyance qu'on mette à
mal
l'intuition peu ce convoqué on peut la
solliciter alors comment faire juste en
se posant une question à laquelle on
veut des réponses
ce qui est intéressant c'est que plus on
va se poser de questions et plus nos
intuitions vont être rendues consciente
donc là c'est intéressant aussi parce
que cela finalement devient quand on
démarre en fait on a un processus qui
est plutôt spontané au départ et plus on
va se poser de questions plus on va à la
solliciter plus elle va devenir un
processus maîtrisé volontaire donc
finalement l'intuition devient un
véritable outil tout à l'heure je vous
disais au début de ce thème que je
croyais beaucoup à l'intuition et que je
croyais beaucoup au fait il ya une
phrase que j'adore de peter pan qui dit
à chaque fois qu'un enfant déclare dans
le monde qui ne croient pas aux faits il
y a une petite fée qui meurt alors si
vous voulez si vous voulez que
l'intuition enchante votre vie à la
façon d'une fée clochette
si vous voulez que votre intuition vous
souffle des réponses qui vous sont
utiles si vous voulez que l'intuition
vous donne des décisions vous aide à
prendre des décisions qui sont conformes
avec qui vous êtes avec puisque ce que
vous voulez faire si vous voulez votre
intuition vous pointe du doigt ou être
au bon endroit au bon moment
croyez en l croyez en votre intuition
croyait aussi également aux vertus du
silence aux vertus de l'ecoute intérieur
et ce sera déjà un bon début
dans votre apprentissage intuitif carbo
l'un c'est cela
l'intuition ça s'apprend ça se développe
et on sait aujourd'hui ça s'apprend et
ça se développe parce que depuis une
centaine d'années dit milliers d'études
scientifiques temps pour une quarantaine
de laboratoires de par le monde ont mis
au jour le processus de perception
spécifique qui est celui de l'intuition
et si on déroule consciemment ce
processus quand se questionnant etc en
s'écoutant eh bien on va apprendre
le déroulé à volonté et donc l'intuition
ça s'apprend et en faisant cet
apprentissage en déroulant consciemment
et bien en fait nous devenons ni plus ni
moins des intuitif plus conscient il ya
une dizaine d'années j'ai tout quitté
notamment mon job
j'ai vendu ma maison ayant compris cela
pour me former à l'intuition
je suis allé aux états unis me former et
je me rappelle très bien
la première toute première formation le
troisième jour l'après midi j'avais mon
instructeur comme disent là-bas m'avait
demandé de décrire un lieu dont je ne
connaissais rien et sur lesquelles il ya
vingt ordinateurs en fait qu elle a
fiché des photographies de ce lieu et
j'avais pas accès à cet ordinateur et je
me suis mis à percevoir faire exactement
le même exercice convient de faire
ensemble tout à l'heure et à percevoir
je vais y arriver
ce lieu est ce que je ressentais c'était
une grande colonne d'eau puissante qui
tombait sur moi et j'ai ressenti comment
ça fait d'être dense où cette colonne
d'eau j'ai perçu aussi des rochers et
j'ai perçu des arbres voilà c'est la
photo de droite
j'ai perçu les arbres et j'ai perçu
l'activité touristique qui étaient
autour de ce petit lac qui en bas ça m'a
énormément marqué est indubitablement ce
jour là j'ai commencé à emprunter le
chemin d'apprentissage intuitif l'air
sympa ta casquette je me serais bien
veniez surtout aujourd'hui fait super
bowl
donc oui l'intuition ou plutôt la
capacité à utiliser son intuition ça
s'apprend alors peut-être que vous avez
encore un peu de mal à y croire pourtant
c'est une réalité
et mieux encore eu l'intuition s'utilise
également dans des contextes
professionnels
pour des problématiques d'innovation de
créativité pour des problématiques
policière archéologiques ou encore
industriels mais là c'est une tout autre
histoire
on espère que vous vous êtes bien ennuyé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]